Alter richtig nice es ist das Ende
glaube ich es ist das Ende alles leute
guckt euch das an Gold Cola Eisen ey oh
servus und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen Folge Minecraft Legend mit
gell ohne John drauf ja so letzte mal
drauf
eingebaut
für heute ist ähm
Rüstung Rüstung Rüstung
wo waren wir vorher da oben ja immer ein
bisschen ich nehme ein bisschen Kohle
mit das war wieder mal die Zeit im Auge
das eigentlich ganz gut
drauf okay ähm genau
23 Eisen oh hä ich kann nicht mehr daran
erinnern was ist das ja letzte Folge es
haben übrigens wir haben so viele
Vorschläge in den Kommentaren bekommen
Namen und auch sehr viele gleich nach
dem Start ist auch wirklich auf Logik
gefallen ja ja wir haben gerade einfach
Team Logo da könnt ihr wenn ihr wollt
könnt ihr uns gerne irgendwelche
schwulen Fanfictions machen weil Team
logame muss damit muss damit umgehen und
das feiern wir also macht uns gerne auf
Fanfictions wenn ihr Bock habt
und ja ich freue mich drauf guck mal mit
runter
so ich habe jetzt oh Leute ich habe
richtig viel gravity
obwohl er relativ weit weg war
in der ersten Folge hat mir ein Herz
abgezogen nachdem ich geblockt habe weil
du weil du reckst hast
ich habe übrigens geschafft diesen
selbst geschriebenen Mods mit kompatibel
zu machen mit meiner mit meinem
Schreibtisch ja Alter das war eigentlich
ganz leicht man muss nur
Rechtschreibfehler einbauen Punkt dann
funktioniert das
ja okay dann komm mit runter bzw ich
fange mal an ich setz mal hier einfach
so einen kleinen Firnis in die Wand nee
und
ähm
was ist das überhaupt
Sülze im Ernst was Sülze im Ernst ich
habe einfach
haben wir Kohle was hast du die Kohle ja
pack mal die Kohle da rein ja ja ich
pack auch mein Eisen rein nee lass mal
die Hälfte teilen ich mache noch 9 oben
so jetzt machen wir das dann haben wir
30 Eisen ich habe richtig viel Getreide
und sowas für Felder können wir mal
gucken was ich so ergibt lass mal oh ja
wie ein Stein für das mal weiter gucken
und runter so Leute ihr könnt gerne
gerne uns übrigens was wir machen können
Hashtag einführen und dann werden wir
solche Farben runden machen ein bisschen
Fragen beantworten oder sowas ja das
können wir auch gerne machen also
schreibt uns doch dafür so eine frage am
besten also wer fragt oder Quest Logo
irgendwie sowas in die Kommentare was
ihr am liebsten Twitter Hashtag haben
wollt dann könnt ihr einfach mal beim
Twitter escape vorbeischauen und Twitter
ad logischer Vogel und dann werden wir
sowas und logische Folie ja und da
werden wir soweit wahrscheinlich mal
machen und ich mache jetzt glaube ich
einfach mal die Minimap aus dann sieht
man nämlich da oben den habe ich vor der
Folge gestanden
oh mein Gott der hat eine Geräusche
gehört hier man sieht wir sind jetzt das
zweitbeste Team anymore ist noch vor uns
was bedeutet eigentlich die Zahl rechts
davon äh die Zahl rechts davon
vielleicht Punkte die Du schon gefahren
hast vielleicht kriegst du ja pro Käse 2
Punkte oder so nee nein auf jeden Fall
sind wir mit ähnlich oder das beste Team
und ja läuft eigentlich bei uns jetzt
gerade gar nicht so viel produktives
machen
wo ist der Ofen hier so wir haben uns
auch vorgenommen natürlich Tränke zu
machen
das kann ich einfach mal zeigen während
und zwar ist in dem modpack nichts
anderes mehr hinzugefügt als noch solche
Nether Schwerter mit Effekten und wir
haben es eigentlich schon eine gute
Taktik hingelegt die wollen aber nicht
direkt offenlegen weil ähm
soll ich meine goldhose behalten mit
Dorn 1 bis die kaputt geht weil dort
eins ist schon ne wenn mich jemand Haut
kriegt das Schaden hast du noch Eisen
gefunden nee leider nicht aber hier ist
ja alles voll mit Eisen da war da war
lustiger ein bisschen Eisen drin okay ja
dann behalt du erstmal die Hose dann
mach mal
ein paar Schuhe weil die weniger
Material brauchen also
Schuhe oder ist eigentlich guck mal die
Kiste rein da habe ich einiges drin
jetzt an Materialien
ja soll ich einfach mal auch mal mein
ganzes Zeug da rein Spam ja erstmal rein
damit wir frei sind nice was was wo hier
auf der Rose
diese diese einfach
aber da sind sicherlich Items aus dem
spawnen deswegen so ja
jetzt erstmal hier runter und noch ist
schön chillig frei das ist ja ganz gut
wir sollten uns ein paar Fackeln machen
damit wir unten was sehen
ja ein bisschen
alles klar melken erstmal zwei Helme und
dann kommen wir genau hin ich bin voll
iron und du bist full iron mit einer
super tollen goldhose ja fast danke
was
gehen wir mal gib mir mal bitte eine
hast du gib mir mal deine eisenhose kurz
die dich aussehen kann
es ist garantiert nicht
goldhose einhalb Rüstungspunkte
eisenhose zu zweieinhalb okay ich
vertraue jetzt einfach mal weiß man
natürlich Spieler so ich habe 36 Fackeln
dann gehen wir mal hier hinten runter
und dann runter runter runter runter
runter runter
überraschen will dann ist haben wir
natürlich auch eine sensationelle
Kampfposition einfach von unten so ja es
fragt mich eigentlich wie weit waren wir
am Sport dran weil die die Kuppel
verkleinert sich ja immer je nachdem wer
stirbt oder wie lange das Bett geht also
wir waren nur ein kleines Stück vom Spa
weg oder oder
weil dann sind wir eigentlich gut
geschützt auch wenn wir hier unsere
Basis machen vor ja passt aber
prinzipiell eigentlich alle Items am
Körper tragen hast du noch eine
Spitzhacke ja habe aber dann geh doch
mal hoch machen
runter auf -13
hat man mit optimale die ja Chancen
ich meine zwischen -15 und -9 oder so
aber ich weiß es nicht ganz genau aber
ziemlich sicher ist minus was habe ich
-13 es hat jetzt ich sehe da unten
leider nichts mehr gar nichts ist
komplett dunkel bei mir oh warte dann
mache ich erstmal einfach ein paar
Fackeln ich mache jetzt aber auch noch
mal schnell ich muss sagen
okay ich werde auch kein Holz mehr ach
da war noch Sticks Leute da mache ich
erstmal Zack und muss meine Steaks hast
du die Sticks nee hier
Spitzhacke machen
perfekt
Alter Leute und die erste Folge ist ja
richtig krass bei Euch angekommen
richtig heftig wir werden auf jeden Fall
weiterhin den Kampf suchen und
vielleicht auch demnächst mal Leuten
nach joinen also alle anderen die das
hier sehen obwohl es nicht sehen dürfen
nein macht euch auch
was gefasst aber nicht wahr
so runter jetzt müssen wir natürlich
aufpassen mit labern ne nicht den Fehler
machen den so viele gemacht haben vor
uns schon nicht unbedingt in diesem
Projekt aber immer nur so Schreck nach
unten bauen ich baue aber auch gerade
wie ein Idiot
wir machen mal nebenbei die Koordinaten
an dann sehen wir
für 21 vielleicht treffen wir noch auf
eine natürliche Höhle das ist natürlich
noch super ist ein bisschen Kohle
Mann
hier du hast dich jetzt ein zu tief
gebaut hör mal kurz auf sonst passt es
13 auf 13 nein nein ich meine von den
Stufen her ist ja falsch platzieren
müssen sogar zwei platziert werden
so zack zack zack zack zack zack ja auf
jeden Fall Leute das haben wir richtig
richtig krass gefreut dass das Projekt
bei euch so gut angekommen ist
nicht mal hochgeladen ne ja also richtig
richtig
schade dass es nicht hochgeladen hat für
mich natürlich ich würde mich liebend
gern mal nicht aus seiner Sicht sehen
ich weiß nicht anschauen
du kannst ja nebenbei theoretisch mal
ich würde mich an die andere Richtung
dann bauen aber also jetzt hier in eine
der anderen Richtung habe aber keine
Fackeln kannst du welche geben dann
mache ich das ja entweder haben wir
jetzt auch nicht ja aber das reicht du
musst ja höchstens alle zehn Blöcke so
du kannst aber mal vielleicht mal
nebenbei so
mal in Minecraft wirklich schauen ich
glaube Diamanten sind echt auf auf 13
die optimal warte ich schau es einfach
mal nach für euch Leute ähm Minecraft
Wiki haben wir natürlich offen hier
nebenbei
zack zack zack zack das ist aber
wirklich das langweiligste wenn man so
ehrlich betrachtet
ein bisschen so ein bisschen zu stripped
mein quasi ja klar aber wir wollen
natürlich richtig machen
ja so genau
ah nee nee nee Diamant Erz findet man
nur in den Schichten von 1 bis 15 wobei
es am häufigsten in den Schichten 5 bis
12 zu finden ist also müssen wir noch
weiter runter noch weiter ich habe
gerade Eisen gefunden chillig egal dann
äh was heißt egal das ist sehr gut
nimmst mit wie tief müssen wir denn noch
eins runter zwei oder drei bis zwölf
dann lass dafür 9 gehen okay
dann machen wir jetzt hier auf Höhe 9
unsere kleine kleine die erfahren und
wir werden demnächst einfach ein Hashtag
einführen einfach #logay auf Twitter
könnt ihr uns dann Fragen stellen die
wir hier bei Antworten
können wir einfach mal gucken was sich
so ergibt für uns und die beiden sich
zusammen ihren Strip mein Gang ihre
Spitzhacken ganz tief ineinander
ich sehe es schon kommen
bei 11 Minuten
wir machen ja nur eine zweite Folge 11
Minuten ja wir produzieren gleich die
zweite Folge und in der zweiten werden
wir mal schauen dass wir vielleicht mal
die ja mir finden hier und vielleicht
und vielleicht auch noch Emerald also
wenn man die ja und Emerald findet
Redstone ist auch wichtig für Tränke
wissen wir kann man überhaupt
aber wir können uns ja auch eine Reisen
ganz schnell machen
ist oh ich habe kein Holz hast du Holz
ja ich habe dabei
gerade noch das coole kohlestück
sehr gut vielleicht sogar gut
abgebaut habe ganz chillig alles klar
dann mache ich hier noch einen kleinen
fördern das hier drin bei mir falls du
den Kaffee mal nicht ja da bringe ich
kurz mal
ein bisschen von dem Eisen rüber was ich
noch habe dann machen wir drüber weiter
während er da hinten brennt damit wir
uns dann nachher den Redstone schaffen
können weil Redstone brauchen wir auch
für unser Vorhaben Tränke
wir haben nämlich ein paar Plätzchen
gemacht für
Franke Menke jetzt geht es weiter weil
wir brauchen
sowieso spätestens wenn wir ähm Dings
finden
kann
wie die anderen Leute das machen die
finden ja extrem
extrem viel
Diamanten scheinbar also Leute unserer
ziel muss es sein Diamanten und Emerald
zu finden weil in der Kombination kann
man Legend Zeug herstellen so man kann
aus Diamant und Emirate kann man sich
Legend Rüstung machen oder aus zwei Dias
zwei Emeralds das Legend Schwert was
stärker als ein Schwert oh Gott aber
einfach Wasser Wasser ich glaube
ja
hast du natürliche Höhle gefunden
mal kurz hier die Monster ausschalten
ganz sneaky und jetzt muss ich hier den
einen Stein Abbauen der mich da noch um
Weiterkommen hindert kannst ja mal zu
mir kommen wir könnten ja zusammen
erforschen ich habe ähm Lilly Pet in der
höchsten ja warte mal ich habe Gold
gefunden und Lava Lava die erste laber
habe ich gefunden sehr gut sehr gut
warte ich mache uns direkt mal einmal
ich zeig mal zwei einmal damit wir uns
dann Lava für und ich habe Redstone
gefunden da muss ich das warte warte ich
mache das Wasser gerade zu ja
Orientierung verloren ja das müsste
jetzt gleich zu sein und es ist
versiegelt ah okay das Wasser sinkt ab
perfekt
Leute
wir haben jetzt
machen
noch kurz
noch den Redstone
zack nehme ich den mit den können wir
nachher gebrauchen für unsere Tränke
sehr viel Gold wenn ich ja oh was ich oh
Gott das glaubst du nicht was ich hier
oh mein Gott
noch mal eine größeres Höhlensystem Logo
hier müssen wir einen anderen mal
ansetzen und das ist richtig nice es ist
das Ende glaube ich es ist das Ende
alles leute guckt euch das an Gold Cola
Eisen ey oh yeah und wir machen weiter
mit der Entdeckung dieses höhensystems
in der nächsten Folge schreibt auf
Twitter unter dem #loge eure Fragen
lowgy lautet der Hashtag eure Fragen die
wir euch beantworten sollen hier in so
einer kleinen Q&A Runde währenddessen
wir Farmen und dann sehen wir uns
nächste Folge wieder drei macht's gut
und ciao und lassen sich gefallen